- And you actually have
your own story, right,
that you're bringing to the table.
And I find insanely possible.
- Thanks!
- Like, go ahead and tell everybody.
They're not going to believe you.
- Yeah, so I weighed 322
pounds about five years ago.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Like, that's incredible.
- Thank you.
So, you know, weighing that
and then coming to be a
trainer on The Biggest Loser
five years later is just insane.
But you know I'm a single mom.
I just beat stage II
thyroid cancer this year.
- Wow!
Congratulations!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Wow, you have had quite a life.
- [Lugo] Yeah, so.
- Just hurdle and hurdle and yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yup.
- And I feel like everything's
kind of brought me to this point.
And to share that experience
and what I've gone through
with the contestants,
I've had to relive that.
And I get what they're going through.
So, for me, it's such a fulfilling thing
to be like, "I get it."
Like those tears you're crying?
I've cried those tears.
Like that burpee you're complaining about?
I've also cried with that burpee.
- Oh my god, I hate burpees.
It's like the devil's work.
- Yes it is.
- It's true though.
I mean, it's completely different
but the analogy of it is
everybody always asks me about The Voice,
what I love about The Voice.
It's the same thing.
I've actually been in their shoes.
And when you're actually
trying to coach someone
that you've been in their shoes,
you feel like you have
some kind of connection
that maybe everybody can't have, you know?
So that's probably, coming
from you, that means a lot.
You know what I'm saying?
That you've been able
to shed all that weight
and like change your life.
- Yeah.
She really put her heart
all over the gym floor
every moment that she was there.
She's the real deal, she really
delivered every single day.
And we're just so lucky to have her.
- Oh my god.
The combination of this is awesome.
(audience cheering and clapping)
So but you're bringing a
new perspective, right?
'Cause you had a heart attack, right?
- I did, it's been almost three years now.
I had a heart attack when I
was living in New York City.
And not only did I have a heart attack,
but I went into cardiac arrest.
So I felt a Biggest Loser
contestant during my recovery
because I went from doing CrossFit
and being able to work
out so hard all the time
to not being able to
walk around a city block
without feeling winded.
Had to change everything
about the way that I ate.
And everything about the
way that I worked out.
And as I was going through my
rehab I was just like, wow.
This is what it feels like
to start back at square one.
And that's what I've gone through.
- Gosh.
Once again, though, it means so much more.
I know that sucks having
had to go through that.
- It's the worst gift you could ever get.
But you know what?
You make something out of it.
- Yeah, you can relate to them, though.
Like people you can relate and say
"Hey, I've had to work
from the ground up, too."
It means something
different when you say that.